you can see even though they're not part
of the lockers itself I've put on D and
s because they define the lockers right
they're part of the definition you don't
have them it's kind of like well what is
this line doing it's just out in the
middle of nowhere doing its thing okay
but as it is you can see there's Richard
and there's me and there's you guys
right and you can go ahead and label if
you draw or if you're you know
reasonably so I count the put Richard
and you you kind of have moles sort of
here so yeah okay no you don't so I've
put on there I've labeled on the
perpendicular angle and you know the
interval D s and and the bisection okay
just to show you okay and you should be
able to even if you don't actually do it
you should be able to do them if it
doesn't look like a right angle
something's gone wrong okay so it should
look slit up in the ballpark
all right we did a circle we did a
straight line what was the last one okay
now how is this work lets up I do a
simple example I'll just leave that
there for a second okay a parabola now
the one we're about to do we're just
going to do basics of it the idea of a
parabola and it's locus is so important
as a whole topic for it later on
it's called very imaginatively Larsen
parabola okay so it's its own topic
we'll deal with it in a lot of detail
for now let's just do the basics so this
is what what example we have to number
three I think okay so they all start off
the same way right a point P
losers such that now do you remember
what was the what were the geometric
instructions I gave you I said there was
a point right person and there was also
a straight line right the wall so it's
equidistant such that it is equidistant
for all let's see here okay again we'll
stick with simple ones let's go
y equals one and let's call this point
all the way around I'm sorry that's
better okay for what it's worth if the
point was on the line it would be a very
easy locus just be a straight line but
anyway okay so there's our y okay now
again for later and this is dealt with
all under the topic that I said before
but you may have heard the word before
somebody's on this unit this line is
called the directrix because what it
does is it defines the direction of the
parabola the parabola we're going to do
it faces in a certain direction you can
make the parabola face in any direction
you like based on the equation of this
line okay
bless you the other points or sides see
the point is called focus okay and
you'll see why in a second okay all
right so how we gonna set this up before
we just had nice easy distance formulas
okay and we will have one distance
formula because we're gonna say the
distance from P to a this point here
right that should be equal to the
distance from P to now I probably should
have given this line a name summer okay
let's call the line L for mine okay so
this is P a should be the same as
distance PL all right left hand side
super-easy what were you doing before
just a straightforward distance formula
okay so I've got the square root X minus
1 squared
okay as you can imagine the right-hand
side is a little trickier right it's not
a distance between two points it's the
distance from a point to a line okay so
this is the perpendicular distance
formula this falls under their quality
geometry revision you have to do at the
beginning of the program if you're a
little shady on it and you yeah what
does it look like okay let's do it
together and let's finish this what's on
the top it's a fraction what's on the
top okay now what's inside here the
easiest way to remember is it's a bit
like general form you notice here I
finished on general form okay that's
probably the best way to leave it I did
it like this exactly graph it okay the
general form is ax plus B y plus C okay
that's general for a straight line
perpendicular distance just a little
different this X and is y what do they
refer to they refer to this point that
I'm measuring from right so it's
actually x1 and y1 okay what are the a B
and C from there from the straight line
right
this lion okay now y equals 1 is not in
general form and I need to put it in
general form so I'll just quickly say
well I guess it's 0.2 X plus 1 1 Y minus
1 okay
do you have to write it like that nerve
but I can see what they be and see up
just to make it easier for what's on the
bottom good and again Coast and
Pythagoras okay all right so let's
quickly just execute this and I'll let
you finish it off to be a lesson later
first the double righty okay so I'm just
gonna write this out with 7 in and then
you can simplify it out so I've got the
absolute value on the top and 0
lots of X
okay there's my setup we'll finish it
this afternoon